Hey there! Mark Sanderson here (also know
as @scriptcat). I want to invite you to my
new seminar ‘Staying In The Game: Surviving
as a Working Screenwriter in Hollywood’
sponsored by Film Courage.
It’s going to be 2 hours of me offering
up my tricks, tips and tactics and disciplines
that can actually help you establish your
own screenwriting career.
Now we’re going to have a Q&A to follow
and also a chance to get my new book. That’sSeptember
25th,Tuesdaynight, from7 to 9 pmin
North Hollywood. Hope to see you there.
Film Courage: What about advice to writers
who have been fired off a project?
Mark Sanderson, screenwriter/author: Well,
there’s a firing and then there is sort
of like “We’re going to go with someone
else.” Which is a firing. It’s not quite
as like “You’re fired!” It’s always
“Thank you very much and now we’re going
to have this other writer finish it.” And
then you share credit.
What I would say to them is learn from what
happened with that particular producer and
not make those mistakes again.
Or maybe they are not as good as a writer
as they thought they were. So they were able
to get in with the script but they weren’t
able to stay on which I think is important
to stay through the end. Luckily on most of
my projects I’ve stayed through the end
and sometimes even been on the set doing rewrites
because the director wanted me there (I had
that relationship with the key members). You
want to stay through the whole thing, you
don’t want to be the person who leaves.
If you’re leaving because you have another
job and you can’t do it, that’s different.
But if you’re leaving because they don’t
want you anymore then you probably won’t
work with that producer again.
Film Courage: What if it’s a combination
of that and politics and you know that? Let’s
suppose there is a little bird in your ear
letting you know that they’ve brought someone
else on and that person has worked with this
other person before. And you know that and
you just kind of half to swallow your pride
and not say anything.
Mark: Well, that happened to me when I was
working on the game show. I was told…this
was earlier…one of my first professional
jobs, I was told that I didn’t have enough
experience to do a certain (during production)
experience. I went through the development
of 6 weeks of writing the show and then they
shoot the show but during that point I was
let go and they said “Oh, we’re bringing
in somebody…” Somebody that had a connection
in the writer’s room. And I thought “Well,
I went through the whole writing, I don’t
understand?” But it was just strange and
I was let go and I was Okay, I understand
but it was hard to be let go because I had
taken that job and I quit my restaurant career
(so called) as a waiter and that was my first
professional job and then to lose it…that’s
why in the book [A Screenwriter's Journey
to Success: Tips, tricks and tactics to survive
as a working screenwriter in Hollywood] I
say how I was fired from my first professional
job.
Film Courage: At Christmas, right?
Mark: At Christmas time, but it happens. You’re
not guaranteed anything. The hardest thing
I had to learn when I first started getting
paid to write was that I thought that everything
I wrote would get made…of course it would
be. Well, I have probably five projects sitting
on a shelf, they’re production ready, I
was paid for all of the drafts…and…nothing.
A myriad of reasons because of marketplace
changes, economics, their buyers decided to
go with a different genre, the actor bowed
out and financing fell through. All things
that were not my problem, I’m just the writer,
right?
That was the hardest thing but it’s not
hard anymore, I’ve realized the realities
of the business. But that was the hardest
thing, I thought that everything I wrote would
be made. I thought when I wrote my specs of
course obviously too. Every spec you write
is going to sell, right?
But to be let go of a job you have to learn
why, it’s a learning experience. You don’t
want that to happen too many times because
then the word will get around and you won’t
work but know your producers and what they
want. And so luckily the producers I know
kind of now after working for so long what
they want. And that’s what they want, they
want to have to leave you alone.
“Arrggghh, is he going to turn in the thing
because we’ve got people waiting and a lot
of money, you know?” They don’t want to
have to worry about that. But you have to
build into that. So a writer that gets in
somehow, luck, maybe whatever, sells the script
but doesn’t have that ability to see it
through to the end, that’s a terrible thing
because you think “Oh, I’ve sold it!”
And you’re not staying on it because you
can’t do the rewrites. Sorry but we need
to take this into production and we need to
get through development, if you can’t do
it, we’ll find someone who can.
Film Courage: How was Christmas that year?
Mark: It was okay, not great because I was
without a job…
Film Courage: Well not only that…sorry to
interrupt but you were leaving one world to
go to this world that you had been waiting
for…
Mark: Yes.
Film Courage: And it’s Christmas…
Mark: I got through Christmas and…
Film Courage: How was New Year’s?
Mark: It was fine because a few months later
my spec was optioned. So I rose from the ashes
like a Phoenix. I didn’t have to go back
to the restaurant and I never did. That’s
my point about having multiple projects of
things. If I had nothing else then I would
be out knocking on doors going “Ahh!?”
But if you charted the course before that
first job, that spec was constantly trying
to find its way and finally ended up with
the proper timing the right home with a company
who said “We want to make it.”